ضموا الينا من المستشفى المعمداني في
مدينه غزه مراسلنا اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل
اذا هناك انباء فادت عن انسحابات للجيش
الاسرائيلي من شمال القطاع اوضح لنا ما
يجري على
الارض نعم قوات الاحتلال اعلنت يوم انس
امس سحب لواء كامل وهو اللواء ال اعتقد لا
اعرف مسماه تحديد لكن صباح اليوم تبين ان
قوات الاحتلال انسحبت مع هذا الصباح من
منطقه الكرامه ومن منطقه المقوسه ومن
منطقه مفترق بهلول ومن منطقه الامن العام
ومن منطقه المخابرات كل هذه المناطق
بالاضافه لى منطقه لتوام وصولا الى منطقه
الواحه بحرا هذه المناطق وهي مساحات واسعه
جدا انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال نحن نتحدث
عن احياء سكنيه بالكامل صباح اليوم
رايناها اختفت بالكامل قوات الاحتلال نسفت
الابراج السكنيه بالكامل بالاضافه انها
دمرت هذه المناطق عرضت لعشرات الاحزمه
الناريه والقاء قوات الاحتلال قنابل
دخانيه وقنابل فسفور قبل ان تدخلها اجبار
لاجبار السكان على الخروج لكن تبين صباح
هذا اليوم حجم الدمار الكبير في هذه
المنطقه ابراج سكنيه كامله وهي عباره عن
احياء سكنيه واقفه وممتده الى الاعلى هي
مدمره بشكل كامل ابراج المقوسه لم يتبقى
منها سوى برج واحد عشرات الابراج اختفت
ابراج المخابرات كلها مسويه مسويه بالارض
وابراج موسى عرفات في تلك المنطقه وياسر
عرفات ايضا مسويه بالارض دمار كب حل بهذه
المنطقه الان عشرات الاف السكان هم بلا
ماوى حقيقي في تلك المنطقه بالاضافه الى
ذلك قوات الاحتلال تراجعت وتركت دمارا
كبيرا في في مجاري الصرف الصحي دمرت البنى
التحتيه بالكامل سواء شبكات الاتصالات
وحتى شبكات الكهرباء شبكات المياه
والشوارع كلها مجرفه بشكل كامل وليست بشكل
جزئي مجرفه حتى هي مجرفه بشكل كامل نتحدث
عن شارع الرشيد الذي يعتبر من اجمل
المناطق وهو متنفس الغزيين الان هذا
المكان اصبح مدمرا
ومجرفة اسماعيل عندما ذكرت تلك المناطق
وانسحابات للجيش الاسرائيلي
منها اين قامت باعاده الانتشار في اي
اماكن
تمركزت نحن نتحدث عن هذه المناطق بالتحديد
بدايه ان هذه المناطق تمركزت بها قوات
الاحتلال قرابه ال يوم ولم تغادر على
الرغم من انها انسحبت من اجزاء كبيره لكن
صباح اليوم انجز انسحبت نحن نتحدث عن ان
سحاد تقريبا شبه كلي من هذه المناطق وصولا
الى منطقه الواحه هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر
على اطراف منطقه بيت لاهيه الان قوات
الاحتلال تتواجد في منطقه المناطق الغربيه
الشماليه وه هي منطقه بيت لاهيه وتنتشر في
ذاك المكان وتاركه المناطق التي هي تعتبر
ايضا من المناطق الشماليه الغربيه لمدينه
غزه التي ذكرتها سالفا الان فقط تتمركز
القوات الاحتلال في المناطق الغربيه
الشماليه على اطراف منطقه بيت لاهيه
المتاخمه لحدود قطاع غزه من المناطق
الغربيه
ا بالنسبه لسكان هذه المناطق التي تحدثت
عنها بانها
ظهرت اليوم وظهر حجم الدمار فيها وقد سوي
بعضها بالارض
تماما سكانها موجودون في مدينه غزه ام
نزحوا الى مناطق
اخرى نحن نتحدث بسبب ضغط النيران الذي كان
في هذه المنطقه اجزاء كبيره من هذه
العائلات نزحت الى جنوب قطاع غزه واجزاء
كبيره راينا ها في ذاك المكان تحاول تفقد
ما تبقى من ركام منازلها لكن قوات
الاحتلال لم تترك حتى بعض ال المقتنيات
لالتقاطها هي المنطقه مسويه بالارض
ومنسوخه بشكل كبير جدا انا اتحدث عن ابراج
سكنيه كبيره جدا وعددها ضخم جدا قرابه ال
50 برج في تلك المنطقه مسويه بالارض ولم
يترك الاحتلال اي ملاذ للمواطنين حتى
للاحتياج في تلك المنطقه كثير من الب من
البنايات السكنيه ايضا مدمره ولا يستطيع
كان حتى السير في الشوارع بسبب التجريف
المستمر والكبير في تلك الشوارع طيب ما
حجم العمل الذي من الممكن بما لها من
استطاعه قوات الدفاع المدني ان تفعله في
تلك الاماكن خاصه بانك تتحدث بان البنيه
التحتيه جرى تسويتها
ايضا نعم حاولت طواقم الدفاع المدني
وطواقم الهلال الاحمر والطواقم المختلفه
انتشال عشرات الشهداء انا اتح تحدث عن
عشرات الشهداء كانت جثمانه على الارض
الكثير منها متحلل في تلك المناطق لم
تستطيع السيارات الدفاع المدني او حتى
طواقم الهلال الاحمر او حتى طواقم
المختلفه للوصول الى تلك المناطق ساروا
على الاقدام كيلوات مترات حتى ينتشروا
الشهداء والكثير منهم بقي في تلك المنطقه
ملقا على الارض لكن لا تستطيع حتى هذه
اللحظه اي من الطواقم عمل ما او افتتاح
تلك الطرق او اعاده تاهيل تلك المنطقه
المنطقه مدمره بشكل كامل ولا تستطيع اي من
الطواقم التعامل مع تلك المنطقه بسبب ما
حل بها من دمار وكان زلزال ضرب مختلف
المناطق الغربيه الشماليه لمدينه غزه اها
ا بالنسبه لهذه المناطق ايضا قوات
الاحتلال عاده عندما تنسحب تنشر القناصه
ما يمنع ويعيق حركه ال السكان لتفقد تلك
الاماكن وايضا الاعمال الاخرى لقوات
الدفاع المدني هل كان هناك تواجد للقناصه
هل لاحظتم اي وجود امني عسكري من نوع ما
لقوات
الاحتلال في هذه المناطق لا تواجد عسكري
لقوات الاحتلال ابتداء من منطقه الامن
العام التي كنا نتحدث عنها قرابه ال 50
يوم قوات الاحتلال وقناصه الاحتلال تمركزت
في تلك المنطقه بالاضافه الى طائرات
الكواد كابتر التي تحلق كانت في منطقه حي
النصر ومنطقه الشاطئ الشمالي ومنطقه حي
الشيخ رضوان الان هذه كل هذه الامور اصبحت
غير متواجده مع انسحاب قوات الاحتلال وصلت
قوات الاحتلال او انسحبت الى اطراف منطقه
بيت لاه هي هذه المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه
المتاخمه للحدود وباقي المناطق الان هي
بلا قوات متواجده يبدو ان قوات الاحتلال
انسحبت بشكل كامل سيرا على الاقدام لكيلوا
مترات مشينا والدمار في كل مكان على مد
البصر وعلى مد العين في المناطق الشماليه
الغربيه حتى لم نلاحظ وجود لقوات الاحتلال
سوى في اطراف منطقه بيتلا هي هذه المنطقه
التي تقع على اقصى الشمال الغربي من منطقه
قطاع غزه لكن قوات قوات الاحتلال تعيد
انتشارها في اليوم التالي وهذا اليوم
يعتبر الاكثر امانا
ونتخذ ان تعيد قوات الاحتلال انتشارها
واعاده تمركزها في مختلف المحاور التي
تنشر خلالها القناصه وطائرات الاكواد
كابتر وحتى المدفعيه الاسرائيليه تضرب
حينها كل من يحاول الوصول لكن هذا اليوم
لم نلاحظ اي تواجد لقوات الاحتلال في
المناطق الغربيه الشماليه شكرا لك اسماعيل
الغول مراسلنا من امام من منطقه المستشفى
المعمداني في مدينه غزه شك شكرا جزيلا لك
و